good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone's having a great day i'm having
a great day because i am joined by
someone i love dearly the most unhinged
person on the internet these days it is
joey camasta mr p everything of the sort
podcast host chef glam artist i don't
even know what to call you hello joey
welcome back to the morning show thank
you for having me now toasters don't be
nervous i'm not jackie but i am as
fertile obviously you're getting the
same hormone imbalance i can confirm
that that is 100 true thank you for
having me i'm so happy to be back it's
been many moons i've been on the couch
we're on a new studio what do you think
it's very i'm very impressed you always
have nice studios and i asked if i could
live here if i fold some hard times yeah
by the way these couches are extremely
comfortable yeah push them all together
you've got yourself a queen bed
there we go yeah a queen for a queen yes
so before we dive in i know you have a
lot of hot takes on pop culture and i'm
very much looking forward to getting
into that yeah i wanted to ask how
you're doing you are making waves you
since the last i started you have like a
whole new career you're at bar school
you host out and about podcast which is
gay culture yes it is so funny like
funny i discovered it on tick tock the
videos like are the highlight of my day
you are so so funny and you have great
banter with your co-host which is so
important yes trish so um it's out and
about you can get anywhere find
podcaster hound and uh me and my co-host
trish we became fast friends and he had
a gay podcast over there at forestry for
a while which wasn't great
excuse me to be honest i mean you know
it's hard to do podcasts by yourself
impossible it's impossible a few of our
mutual friends do it and i don't know
how they do it it's like you know i need
someone to banter off of so when we
found each other we were like two peas
in a pod and just as inappropriate and
just as wild and messy um you know so
it's good it's called out and about and
it's so good at foursome sports and i
yeah i'm a career one at barcelona i
know you're like an office girly how is
that going because you have not been in
office girly no i haven't had a job for
eight years
um
so i've looked you know i've been
sitting on my bed like working from home
right about we were comfortable here for
the pandemic yeah right now we were
working from home before it was socially
acceptable yeah so now i go into the
office every day but that's kind of like
part of the job as you're going to the
office and basically you're just like
it's a like the hype house that's
basically it's like 10 hours right
you're just like you know you're at your
desk but like yo you're getting pulled
like one day the tick tock little girl
come down like can you come with me for
a second and they'd drag you over here
they'd make you do this i had to eat
bull testicles the other day i'm
lowering the bar how was that it was you
know
it's disgusting they eat disgusting
things on that show it's fun though it's
a great is that the premise of the show
you just eat groceries crochet you're
pretty much yeah
they're like eyeballs one day and
pigs um they're a bull penis that's all
disgusting that's called lowering the
bar that's another podcast so you get
pulled on that to do that right you know
there's every day something new you
never know what you're gonna get
yourself into and then celebrities there
are like wild
that's probably the coolest part like
literally i bumped into who wasn't like
julian edelman was like they're the
other guy that looks like a disgusting
hog jewish king i love him yeah um when
you eat bull testicles is that a fork
and knife situation yeah well they cook
it
they skinned it
and they cooked it and then um it was
like it was like a texture of like
regular like like vegan breakfast
sausage whereas
it's like crumbly yeah um and
yeah it's disgusting and that sounds
horrible shark was the worst fermented
shark it smelled like [ __ ] like like
a ammonia litter box in there for out
for days disgusting can you say no yeah
you can say no but like you want the
clout well i want to go on it so i want
to a lot of time now they know
i'm not up to their [ __ ] and i won't
be doing it but i just go for sound
bites i'll go to the bar and just be
like you know just give me some sound
bites and i'll like i'll you know hang
out but um yeah every day is a new
adventure you never know what you're
gonna get i love that it's fun yeah and
i just meet so many people the straight
boys alone they probably love these
there's so many cute boys there that
must be tough yeah no what are the
policy on intro office right well you
know when you sign on at barstool that
like
the contract is like like the hr part of
it is very like
like you know you're going to be
involved in situations right of course
there's going to be foul language
there's going to be you know
inappropriate situations
outline it so you're going to know what
you're getting in for so yeah it's not
it's not officey in that sense you know
you can like
you know i try not to get in trouble but
yeah so i don't you know i can't really
grab a guy's ass but i could allude to
the fact that i would want to you know
chow down on that thing
[Laughter]
you are unhinged how long have you been
there now um i started february 1st
officially but i was there you know you
have to like you have to go perform for
like dave's horny for like
yeah for like months so you have to kind
of get in there it's like you know
because it's almost like hazing uh-huh
in a way so you have to like you know
kind of hang out there and like get to
know everyone and see if the vibe fits
and then eventually they'll offer you a
contract i love that yeah so you know of
course i was you know i was there for a
while you know things everyone liked it
and i had fun so good why not it's not
i'm having so much fun over there and
you know what when i saw you on the out
and about podcast first on tick tock i
thought that was the perfect place for
you like i think it's so great i'm so
happy if you're still hosting your
podcast with snooki yes you guys do live
shows we're doing our live shows you can
always find me and it's happening with
snippy and joey um anywhere fine
podcasts are found and we are actually
going on tour fun we're following my
little sister's footsteps um slowly but
surely yeah
we will be at the uh wilbur theater oh
fun wilbur theater um gorgeous venue i
think that's the second house so first
foxwoods is the tenth june 10th gorgeous
at fox with casino me and snooki from
jersey shore we have our pockets it's
happening and we are we while out it's
like it's like you're like yours get
wild
my fans are disgusting oh really
disgusting low brow
not below brown they're just they're
just wild like they're
out the gate like like they're out of
prison for for 24 hours and they're
going to piss themselves they're going
to throw up they're going to get you
know
they're going to take their tops off
they're going to [ __ ] a stranger like
they come out to get [ __ ] up right and
like you can't like you would you
wouldn't be able to have a show because
you actually have like legit like
planned out jokes right if they're
screaming the entire time that's fun
it's the best girls night out you'll
ever have in your life and it's like
wild just be prepared because it's wild
so that's foxwoods and then we go to
wilbur theater the next day and then
we're doing bergarata
have you done that i love no but i love
the borgata yeah i've never been i've
been there i've never performed there i
did atlantic city uh tropicana which was
harassed yeah it was more money so it
was good but it was less you know
stunning than the borgata yeah still
good time was had yeah so you can go to
nicolepolizzy.com
nicoleblizzy.com to buy tickets um for
the remaining shows and then we know
we'll pick our tour up there but yeah
i'm a busy beaver you know you're so
busy and one thing i forgot about you or
maybe i never really realized and this
is where i was i
that how's it reading on camera guys no
this camera actually um loses 30 pounds
for you so that's why we all look so
stunning on the show um what i was going
to say is i do not remember you talking
so fast and that's coming from you don't
know maybe it got worse i haven't taken
my pills yet it definitely got worse i
should slow down no take your time be
yourself but i just didn't remember that
about you and if i'm noticing it that's
bad well they call your mama mouth mabel
okay what
marvel mouth mabel oh love her yeah
well i do talk fast huh yeah that's
always been a downfall of mine
especially in the broadcasting industry
yes it's like could we have chosen a
worse career like doing live events
where you have to be on camera on stage
and then being on camera during the day
no half the time people do not
understand what i'm saying i don't even
say the sentence i just swallow it
completely well in new york we speak
fast as is this so when you go to like
the sticks you're probably like they're
probably like come again yeah no and i
really have to like slow down i could do
my show like i have the whole show
memorized i could do it in 30 minutes or
i could do it in 90 minutes just because
that's the best feeling in the world
it's like your homework's done and
you're not terrified
you don't honestly if you don't do what
we do it's the best [ __ ] feeling that
is the best
analogy for it like your homework is
done and you don't have to worry about
the next day you can go to sleeping you
can hang out with your friends you don't
have to worry about like knowing your
material knowing what you have to do of
course just going to every city you want
to tailor your things and if someone you
know screams or something you have to be
prepared for everything but knowing
you're set and having it done and not
having to worry you i can go in front of
a billion people i can i can go on the
world stage it's so true like if you
feel confident in your very nervous
about if you know what you're doing it's
so true yes oh my god i love that that's
a perfect analogy you have it down in 30
minutes well i could do it in 30 minutes
but i want to give people a nice long
show and when i i'm excited to see
what's new here now i watch your special
your hulu special oh no no no you're
special
loved that thank you so much and now are
you wearing pajamas this time or no am i
wearing pajamas this time um i wouldn't
say pajamas it's an elevated loungewear
luke okay some pajamas now is it a
natural fiber
um it's not breathable if that's the
question because i have to dry clean
them every time i wear them how many
sets do you have four okay good because
like if i do four shows in a row i
cannot wear the same set they're soiled
like i can't wear the same set more than
once i have to dry clean it in between
when was the last time you soiled your
pants joey
so well my pants
probably when i [ __ ] in the uber
did you hear about that
no i didn't you never heard one i
haven't seen you since then i [ __ ] full
[ __ ] in the in my hand catch and release
and i was like oh my god wait i'm sorry
start from the beginning where was this
uber taking you was it uberx it was the
first monster
outing to the short hills mall in new
jersey okay i was going there for to go
get free sheets from this very fancy
place and i had to go there to show face
in the store to get to an influencer
scam right right together
for betty for betting you were
influencing influencing and in the short
hustle money jersey i decided after i
said you know what i'm feeling frisky i
just got i just got a thousand two
thousand dollars worth of bedding for
free and i was on a high a natural high
horse so i went shopping around i went
to you know vineyard vines and i bought
a couple of things there and then i went
to
um i think a-stop and bought a bunch of
soaps i had a bunch of i was doing some
shopping the short hills mall is
extremely bougie oh it's madison avenue
in a mall it is yeah i used to work
there as a young girl oh where at the
makeup counters
cute for what store mac cosmetics love
yes i worked at matt cosmetics in that
store there for for years but yeah
shorthand monitors it's beautiful
gorgeous okay continue so i said you
know what i'm gonna head back to the
city um let me have a little feeling a
little peckish so i said let me get what
is peckish mean package means like
hungry like one of the little pickings
got it wow i need to that's the word i
need legal seafood
it should be called illegal seafood
and i decided to get the sashimi
oh no
in the mall or at home in the mall okay
legal seafood it's like not as bad of a
place here it's a cream fancy and we're
in a fancy mall it's beautiful glassware
you thought it was safe
i didn't even think anything of it not
still to this day i don't think it was
the
sashimi so hey the sashimi i call the
uber black no it was a regular uber i
think it was a camry okay
we go we get going who's we me and the
driver oh okay i had like three pinot
grigios i had some shishimi sushi you
cannot say the word sushi can you say it
sashimi sashimi
sashimi yeah
i had the tuna sashimi
and i get so the uber's there so the guy
and his name is mohammed i'm not making
this up
he gets he's driving i'm in the over i'm
behind the passenger seat here
it's getting like dusk time like like
rush hour and i'm starting to feel like
you know like oh my god i have to like
pay so i had to pee pee pee and then
finally got um beverly and i feel like i
had to [ __ ] and i was like oh my god but
it wasn't regular [ __ ] like it was like
the one that's like a hat it's like
evacuate the dance floor it has it has
to come out
it's like and then you get that cramp
and if you're holding you pinch it in
it's like stabbing you in the middle
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
like no way there's no way out so i was
like okay now we're like we're on a
highway i was like i can't
i can't like what am i gonna do i can't
pull i didn't know what to do i'm a
little tipsy at the time right
it got so bad where i was like no so
like let me like you start thinking like
um bargaining with yourself okay like
how bad will the cleanup if i just like
a little little out can i sit with it
for the rest of the ride right just to
get the stabbing pains away can i let it
can i let a little out
a modest amount
okay
just nothing crazy just a little
something right you thought it would
stick to the girl the whole thing just
gotta stop the stabbing pain right
well i just i tried a little i know it's
like and then it was like no then the
hat painting coming i think this gotta
get it that's gotta get out of me so my
brain i thought i went to the bag and
took tissue paper
from the sheets
no tissue paper from like the gifted get
it from the bag yeah the gift bags i
took the tissue paper i went down the
back of my pants
i cannot breathe i lift it up like this
and i released
i released in the thing and then i i had
it i bought it and i threw it out the
window
wait
and then that and then i was like oh my
god and now now we're stuck in traffic
now we're like in the city like we
crossed the gwb
and now we're like like in the
deep bronx the thick the thick of things
in the bronx on a highway a three-lane
highway
that's bumper-to-bumper stopped traffic
i was like oh my god oh my god
you still had to go at this point yeah i
i i catch you really sidestep three to
three times you catch and release all
over and it's it's like oh on my hand it
was disgusting
did you ask the driver no i didn't like
a paper towel no i just i had to very
discreet the whole time do you think he
smelled it [ __ ]
i'm sure he did because i got i got a
[ __ ] 300 bill
into my account oh you did so listen so
then i go and then i couldn't take it
anyway so i had to get out of here so it
was because i knew the traffic and i was
like i just had to get out of there
right into a demo my hand is covered
there was nothing we're on a highway oh
so i had to i got out of the car i had
to hop two barriers in the middle of the
thing climb a fence on the side and walk
through the woods the jungle woods and
the pitch knight black in the middle of
the bronx until i fight for like like
and then as soon as i got out of the car
i [ __ ] in the woods like a [ __ ] bear
i was gonna say weddings
my underwear off i took i took
everything off and like wiped it like in
the middle i was black in the woods and
then i finally found a civilization like
45 minutes later walking through the
through the bronx in the woods on the
side of the highway
i finally find civilization and then
like
i got i walked to a cab and like threw
everything out like everything i owned i
was like basically right thank god i
bought like extra clothes at the at the
moment
at the thing so here's the question was
all of this worth the free sheets
they're bowling branch they're very nice
bowling branch are stunning now i got
the waffle flap i got the waffle um
thread blanket throat i got the down the
the the duvet insert i got the pillows i
got it was worth it okay good okay well
that's
and i got the cleaning fee for that poor
man um three i i wanted to give him more
yeah of course
only for the you know the torture alone
inconvenience right who does that
you
mall sashimi mall sashimi will do that
too well let that be the lesson of
today's toast mall sashimi is not your
friend
that's right
um thank you so much for opening up and
sharing your vulnerable moment with you
with us we really appreciate that now
are the toasters is potty is potty talk
are they grossed out by are they
we actually have started a lot of potty
with a young uh oh little little mama
over here she's gonna have a lot of
potty talk well right she's video hers
but you know what we um on mondays we
started this new segment called unburden
yourselves where people just write in
and unburden themselves from the about
burden
unburdened like you know when you do
something embarrassing when you're drunk
and it haunts you
i hide into the covers for days right
but so like sharing that information
unburdening it onto other people really
does help with the process of healing
yeah so we have people write in to
unburden themselves and it's always
something poop related oh good you
should i don't want to gross everyone on
my picture my big return no we your big
return is off to a great start
the toasters are very poop friendly and
again this is a safe space for you to
heal thank you and we really appreciate
you being so open and honest thank you
um so i think that's probably a great
place to start today's show yes so we
are going to do deer tonight do that
still or not we do we do i'll let you
know when it's time
we do have deer toasters today which is
our advice segment which i did save
specifically for you i just feel like
you would give some particularly
unhinged
old hoe i got lots i got lots of advice
you have lots of knowledge lots of
experience and i think you're going to
be great under your toasters i'm excited
but before that let's deliver the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
you can do it it's on the soundboard but
not quite it's more like a
perfect
and today's episode is brought to you by
purple there are all these gimmicks that
promise a great night's sleep but we
don't care what kind of toppers there
are or how heavy a blanket may be it's
all lipstick on a pig because if you're
sleeping on a terrible mattress your
sleep will be terrible and it's that
simple and that's why we really
recommend sleeping on a purple mattress
that's because only purple mattresses
have the gel flex grid the gel flex grid
is amazingly supportive for your back
and legs while cushioning your shoulders
neck and hips no matter how you sleep
unlike memory foam which remembers
everything thanks to the gel flex grid
purple mattresses bounce back as you
move and as you shift so you never have
that i'm stuck feeling that you get with
memory foam you know i'm a big fan of
purple mattress my smelly pillow is
purple mattress and that's the gel flex
texture it's really a stunning
supportive fabric perfect for a mattress
perfect for a pillow
and you can try your purple mattress
risk-free with free shipping and returns
and financing is available too so
getting a great night's sleep starts
with having a great mattress get a
purple mattress go to purple.com
tmt and use the code tmt for a limited
time you can get 10 off any order of 200
or more that's purple.com
tmt code tmt for 10 off any order of 200
or more purple.com tmt promo code tmt
terms apply today's episode is also
brought to you by figs figs is on a
mission to make awesome scrubs suited
for awesome humans working in healthcare
forget boxy itching itchy cotton scrubs
figs are engineered to be ridiculously
soft and incredibly durable using their
innovative technical comfort technology
figs blends comfort style and durability
into high performance scrubs that help
you perform at your best whatever the
day throws at you so it's no secret that
i am not a nurse but i do own about
three pairs of figs because they're
extremely comfortable like pajamas and
you know me like for me comfort is key
and it's great for the nurses it's great
for me i love a stretchy material i love
something soft
they're modern scrubs with a focus on
design function and comfort their
proprietary four-way stretch fabric is
ridiculously soft and we'd love a
stretchy moment because you just never
know what kind of sashimi is going to
come along
they have up to 20 pockets on some style
so if your pockets girly you know
the jam they're super popular core
scrubs never go out of style
and you can mix and match any core
scrubs with each other for quick
wardrobe refresh figs believe that the
awesome humans in healthcare deserve
scrubs that much so head to
wherefigs.com and use the code toast to
get 15 off your first order that's w e a
w-e-a-r-f-i-g-s
dot com code toast for 15 off your first
order all right joey are you ready i'm
ready to dive right in well the big news
of the day yesterday is something that
hits particularly close to home for me
cuba gooding jr pleads guilty to one
count of forcible touching this is from
the cut cuba gooding jr walked out of a
manhattan courtroom on wednesday a free
man after pleading guilty to one count
of forcibly touching a woman in a
nightclub in 2018 gooding will continue
to have alcohol behavior modification
treatments for six months after he will
be allowed to be replete
after he will be allowed to re-plead to
harassment which is a lesser charge and
have the case sealed gooding was first
arrested and charged in new york city
after allegedly groping a woman without
her consent in 2019 days later comedian
claudia ashrae accused him of touching
her without consent when she was 16 in
2012. thank you that was i was thinking
this is your case no the cut put me in
and you know what a repeat offender uh
he is so nuts and by the way the fact
that he's like pleading guilty and he's
gonna be fine and like nothing's ever
really gonna happen to him when i wish
you could see my dm's like the craziest
stories maybe 50
people saying he kissed me and i didn't
i was just he was walking by me kiss me
grab my vagina like crazy [ __ ] he's
disgusting he's literally a monster and
you know what good on this one girl who
got her case all the way to an actual
trial yeah but like he's gonna be fine
he's gonna remain sick he's sick you
know what's [ __ ] up about that kind of
situation is that
the court system or whatever it will say
like you know it's so easy for him to
say these these women are gold diggers
and they just want my money and they
want to say that i did this without
proof
it's disgusting if you saw like back in
the day by the way and when
when he was first accused i didn't say
this article is like kind of wrong i
didn't say days later that it happened
to me too i've been telling this story
forever because it was the craziest
thing like when i was literally in high
school this man stuck his finger up my
butt at a club and it was just this
thing i always told people and then it
obviously got picked up when you knew
who it was that night well you know what
i didn't like immediately recognize him
but there was another celebrity there
with him standing right next to him and
i knew that person and i was like
oh my god that's mark cuban and then
cuba was with him um there's a lot of
cubes going on yeah i know it's very
confusing so
the amount of messages it's so crazy
he's literally an animal like he's
disgusting and i'm glad there's like
some sort of punishment but it's not
nearly enough the punishment does not
fit the crime
and it's gross
it's disgusting he's disgusting i
literally hate this man oh what i was
saying was if you saw like some of the
people mentioning me on twitter
when i first like when this got picked
up that he had done it to me do they
call it they were yeah
liar
fat ugly girl i hope you get cancer of
the anus
[ __ ] crazy like that's how much
people don't want to believe that like
he is this person but i swear on
everything i own he is that person well
obviously he's just a repeat offender
yeah um and that has to be some kind of
weird fetish nothing probably can't get
women it's probably it's probably like a
he he wouldn't go as far as doing
much more horrible things like that so
he's like getting a little taste of like
right no you're right he's successful it
has to be a fetish or some weird [ __ ]
up thing because it shouldn't be hard
for him to get girls why does he have to
be
it's a weird [ __ ] up fetish what a
sicko he's so sick and i literally hate
him and you know i've run into him like
two or three times since that day and he
has no idea who i am like he would look
me down in the eye and just like walk
past
what if
remember me now
literally um
he's so scary i hate this man with every
fiber if you shoot him would you scream
and if you got a water would you scream
show me the money in court with him is
that a line for one of his movies
oh yeah he's jerry maguire yeah i'm so
unfamiliar with his catalogue of work
except um snow dogs iconic disney
channel movie um but other than that i'm
really not familiar with his line of
work he's not we don't really claim him
yeah the girls in the gays don't really
claim him no not at all he's not like an
icon in any way he's a monster and you
know who is anna zelvey
how so
what are you feeling when i don't know
what your scandal is with her oh i don't
have it i don't know your opinion on her
um i think she's like the biggest loser
of all time who became like a famous
loser and i think the way people are
obsessed with her it's like a little
over the top like she wasn't that
interesting but i thought the show was
good i was really into the story like
when it first came out but now it's like
so many tv shows you have you've run
into little
high society circles have you ever seen
it so you know what the elusive elusive
anna when i was watching the
netflix show i was actually thinking
like i must have been especially like
when she was at the height of her
scandal stardom i was like you know
thirst monstering like different circles
and i totally feel like i must have met
her i have no recollection no proof i
don't know that i did but i i can't
imagine that i haven't been in the same
room as her i'm sure you have i know i
was thinking about that a lot and i was
waiting for them to like you know have
one of her friends in the show be
someone that i recognize yeah but i
didn't
we go have you been
no i've not met and that i know of right
um i'm fascinated by it though i don't
know how i feel i don't i don't have an
opinion either way i just you know it's
sort of the ultimate thirst monster no i
know and like the way she was able to
literally con every single person in new
york when people in new york are so
yeah
like aware of your [ __ ] yeah we can
check facts yeah like they don't get
scammed easily and she was out here
scamming the top of the top would you go
to the nfl foundation um yeah it sounds
like zero bond like a cool soho house
members club yeah if i could get a
membership i probably would have tried
to get one back in the day
for free of course no for barter social
barter yeah
next to the statue here sorry to go off
topic she was just that's such an iconic
thing i haven't seen you yet i know i
know it was like a crazy um moment in
time and i thought that the netflix show
was really good what did jackie think of
it
jackie um
jackie's like decided that she's over
the anna delby stuff like she
jackie was actually the one who showed
me that first vanity fair article and
like explained the whole thing to me and
then but then it just became like so
overdone it's like a million
documentaries american greed netflix now
it's like the same story being told over
yeah and it's like a little bit
overplayed i think that's how jackie
feels yeah and i agree
if you if you were to be like a
socialite who scammed everyone like what
would your story be like if i were to
sit down one day and watch the
documentary of joey camasta like fraud
yeah what would you have done um
well i probably i wouldn't care about
clout and things like that
or fame i'd probably do some more things
about like manipulating straight boys
married men married men for sure yeah i
could definitely see that documentary
being made one day yeah i could see you
on americans that um maybe
the um
maybe some like shady like surgeries or
like weight loss secrets yeah yeah
like if i lost a bunch of weight when i
said i really dyed it but i really was
having my body sucked out every like
right do you have any weight loss
secrets you want to share i'm always
open to hearing new ones well
i know we're not good at diets
no
it doesn't really work i mean i try to
get i'm trying like to get down because
i have to you know be i have to go on
the road i told you i know can we talk
about that
i got permission before and so i don't
get sued by dave portney yeah of course
because you were telling me about this
new thing you're doing which honestly
sounds like horrible and amazing i know
you tell me you're going on a new show
for barcelona road rules it's like road
rules it's quite like roads it's called
barstool versus america and basically um
we go to travel around around the
country in these rv buses like a tour
bus a tour bus it's almost like you know
yeah it's a tour bus so you sleep in
like those bunks yeah there's four
people four it's eight partial employees
um on two different teams so four and
four and there's two different buses and
we travel across the country and while
we're it's all sponsored by high noon
sunsets i know i can't say that you can
high noon is good high noon they have a
new flavor it's called guava it's so
good it's not as good society cause
they're different
this is why i know the high needs are
great and so they're sponsoring the
whole like seriously the whole thing
it's all behind you but the thing is
we're going to be doing the fun part
about it so i love doing is we're going
to get to do meet and greets and these
happy hours these high noon happy hours
all across the country oh cute so um if
anyone wants to you know that's going on
we're leaving next week so check your
local listings we're going to start off
in tampa
fun then we're going to are you driving
from new york to tampa you fly to tampa
campus and start the whole journey but
we have to stay on the bus the whole
time that's insane and they do all these
challenges in between in between meet
and greets and cities we have to do like
physical challenges like running and
mazes and
sports i guess how do you think you're
going to fair with the sports well i
think there's the good thing is other
straight boys there
not other there are straight boys there
right besides you know not i'm not a
straight boy you're not no well i'm
thinking about it there's just there's
two girls two gays and four straight
boys okay
um so that's a good mix yes so these
there's two straight boys on every team
hopefully who will like you know carry
the loads we'll do all the stuff
literally yeah and i'll like you know do
there's something the mind games of the
puzzles we actually remember like the
flavors of the high noons and the order
like and like line up the cans and do
all these things you'll be good at the
seconds the brain games the brain games
um and then what do you win if you win a
challenge you win a bunch i think well
the thing is i think within last season
what you do is you win you don't you
just get an airbnb for the night in that
city instead of sleeping on the bus
heaven that's the thing but the whole
goal is the whole big thing is you win a
bunch of money i don't know how much
money and a house a shore house for the
whole summer on the jersey shore oh my
god stunning you have to win yeah would
you invite me to your house well trish
won last year pat one last oh your
co-host toast pat so you your co-host
name is pat pat you can follow that
barcelo pat on instagram and twitter and
you call him trish palm trish why oh
anyone my mother my late mother parted
i'm sorry um that's okay she's i always
laugh
um it's fine i'm there too
is your dad
sisters sisters um
so
oh anyone everyone should name patricia
or pat she would say may i call you
trish oh my god that's so funny
like i always call anyone named um
because of your mom yeah that's so sweet
and it's such a fun thing it's like you
know may i call you trish and she's such
a fun name what do you call me i call
you claudia claudia i like that or the
girl in her job do you still do um
what is that thing you always say
i'm so we're doing oh sorry we're going
to tampa then we do nashville fun um
madison was not messed up yeah wisconsin
that's a place i don't think that's it
though oh okay milwaukee no it's another
it's another name in wisconsin maybe um
green bay i don't know [ __ ]
why don't i literally have never maybe
just madison wisconsin that's like the
only one i've heard of is that like wild
milwaukee is in wisconsin no it's not
that one i think it's imagine wisconsin
okay um chicago and boston fun so check
your local lessons from high noon to
boston
from
yeah is that so far well if you start in
tampa and you end in boston that's
really far yeah it's cross country well
kind of well thank god they keep you
stuck with high noons and you drink
those the whole time right yeah so i
know so i have to be happy topless i
don't know what they're going to make me
do so i probably just got exciting oh so
you're just trying to trim down down
from barcelo versus america okay because
i don't want to um be like like a slob
kebab on tv with like my top off well
you're perfect the way you are thank you
but dining tips you know you just got
you know what you have to do girls
there's no secret you can't eat the good
stuff you can't eat bread or rice or
candy or sugar pasta you have to eat
like just grilled
meat and just just like meat and
vegetables that's it and that's why
that's why i don't know alcohol and
that's why i'm becoming a cannabis queen
leading up are you i think so well yeah
the alcohol like what you just eat so
much and you act like an animal well the
alcohol you know wine not wine you can i
drink lots of wine and then i drink lots
of cocktails i drink a lot because when
you're drinking i can have like not even
lying to you if i was drinking spritzes
i could probably do
how many of them before four i could
probably do
24 by myself in a night really probably
wow i'd love to see that i party long
nights right yeah you know i start i
start at happy hour and i go to a little
while in the morning yeah so it's like i
while out so that's what that's all
those calories everything has calories
in it so you can eat it you drink
calories which and then
i'm eating because you're drunk you end
up being losing ambitions and eating
whatever the hell you want of course but
then also that happens with pot too like
you get so hungry you get so hungry but
the thing is you're not eating you're
not drinking you're smoking you smoke a
little bit of pot or take one edible
there's zero calories yeah but then
until you're saving binge
yeah but i don't think the bench
community is bad as doing this and then
binging i agree that's true you're
cutting out at least you are saving some
calories so ladies go find a drug dealer
okay you want to buy some marijuana okay
get yourself a puff pan get yourself an
edible yeah i love that um get yourself
a tincture
a tincture there's so many ways to do it
now it's true
i've never tried three chi no what is it
like delta eight it's like it's a
different strain so we can sell it
everywhere
oh no they send me stuff all the time it
is so [ __ ] good three cheats and it's
like it rocks your world and they have
every every every every um
application you can uh
you can have droppers you can have a
little gum
a cream right
um put it into your food like you can
there's every waste you can get in your
body it's like smoke it stuff it inject
it yeah inject it what i love you got it
they got it all i love that for you and
what about an anal suppository
why not why not um well thank you for
sharing that again for being open
honestly i'm very open and honest here
and we love that and we this is a really
like safe non-judgmental space your fans
are die hard they would kill they would
murder for you guys and they love you so
i think we're all just getting closer as
we sit here
but i'm gonna move on to the next story
because at this rate this will be a
[ __ ] four-hour episode [ __ ] cuba
justice has been served but like not
enough justice um people magazine is
talking about one of the most iconic
moments in last night's episode first
premiere episode of the kardashian show
on hulu
um kim kardashian is crying to kanye
over the threat of the second sex tape
in the kardashians premiere so it was
really crazy
so i didn't really even know this whole
story but basically they're having a
barbecue and saint comes over with his
ipad
and he's playing roblox and he's like
mom look roblox and she takes the ipad
and you know that picture of kim crying
when she's like
when she yeah when she's talking about
chris humphries divorce yes so it's a
picture of her crying and thank god sync
doesn't know how to read but the
headline says leaked footage coming soon
of kim kardashian sex tape new footage
and she grabs the ipad and it's like
freaking out and over the course of the
episode she finds out that ray j's
manager is like shopping this around um
trying to get there's more footage that
she didn't know about and she is on the
phone with her lawyer
then she calls kanye and she's just
crying and it's so sad by the way like
yeah and what she says she's like you
know what i'm not gonna let this bother
me it's 20 years old
and i made a mistake 20 years ago and
then she was like you know what i don't
even i didn't make a mistake i was with
my boyfriend exactly how she clarified
that yeah she was like i didn't do
anything wrong i was in love we did
something that a lot of people do and
who knew rachel would turn out to be
such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and
his manager so the episode was left with
a to be continued but then next week we
saw a little premiere and i'm pretty
sure what happens is like she's sitting
there getting ready for snl
some something someone drops off a
suitcase and it's kanye and she opens it
up and starts crying and she's like guys
look what kanye dropped off and she
opens it and they cut it but i'm pretty
sure that's the laptop with all like he
got it back for her
with all the footage and like she's
crying it's so sweet and i've been on
this like kanye hate journey for the
last couple months because he's been
harsh love bothering me um but now after
last night's episode and i think what
happens next week i'm like back on the
love train and now i'm like hoping that
they get back together i'm so excited
for that i know yeah that'd be nice
connie and cam yeah
i mean i'm actually still like really
big fan of kim and pete yeah but i
totally skeet i totally love
kanye now it was so sweet have you seen
the first episode i saw the second
episode too i know i didn't wanna i
don't know if you were allowed to say
that so oh i don't know if i am
definitely not i
didn't see anything
i didn't see [ __ ]
um the first episode and what i thought
it was interesting about this is that
do you think they did this
not
they had a choice to watch the first
episode do you think they put the sex
tape in the first episode of this like
they did in the first episode of keeping
all the kardashians for good luck well
that's what chloe said chloe was like
this is an omen you know the first
season of keeping up we were talking
about the sex tape and now first season
of this show we're talking about it so
it must be a good sign i actually
thought that was like a funny and kind
of good perspective yeah and obviously
that did not calm kim down but i agree
like i think so random like i when i
think of kim i don't even think of sex
tape like it's so old and it's such like
a [ __ ] antiquated way of like looking
at women in business it's so stupid um
but i agree i think it's definitely
eerie like and i don't think they
planned it that way i don't think i love
it because it's nostalgic in a way and
it's like you know it's it's almost like
it's it's horrible to say it's because
she's going through so much bad things
but it's like it's like a feel-good
moment for the viewer no totally like
almost like we like we because we're at
a new poem because we used to be an e
now we're on hulu so i feel like we're
like we're like on vacation so it feels
like some kind of familiarity
a hundred years talking about yeah we're
at a different house different camera
different style so many drones i love
the drones okay i did two but they went
a little over a little bit like it's
reminding me of [ __ ] laguna beach it
was making me nauseous like they showed
like positions she will get motion
sickness yeah no like i had to take a
dramamine they were literally showing
pacific coast highway and then the drone
went upside down like why do we need to
see pacific coast highway upside down
kendall and her sound bath like it was a
lot
and kendall wasn't even in the episode
like at all
shown yeah kylie like i guess hasn't
happened because she's pregnant and
kendall had an excuse because she had
coveted yeah but once again it's
courtney kim and chloe putting the show
on their back even though they said in
press that they are splitting the money
equally so everyone else yeah everyone
has to show up equally that's fair this
isn't like
a ki boots like just between the five
girls and the mom and the mom yeah
i wonder if scott scott had his own
little thing they had his name besides
they keep keeping it in there yeah it's
nice that they're keeping him in there
but i can't imagine he's like a
full slice of the pie no no
um i like everyone says that courtney
doesn't show court is my favorite
kardashian by the way i know him
kim is your kim is mine yeah yeah
courtney's my favorite i think it's like
her dry sense of humor i think she's the
funniest well that was funny she doesn't
try they were talking about snl she's
like well everyone thinks chloe and me
are the funniest like really i never
thought you were the finest i think
chloe is yeah
um she actually said they say she's the
lazy ones that want to share anything
her life she's the only one who shared
everything with her life the entire she
pulled a baby out of her vagina true
with her bare hands it's true i put it
on her chest she had um scott was a
nightmare and she showed every horrible
thing with scott true now she's showing
her things she shows more than anyone
and with the travis stuff she's being
super open you're very fun with it
though i know she's definitely lighter i
think like the last couple seasons of
the old show she was like kind of a
misery yeah because she was miserable
like i didn't think she was in a good
place in her life and now you can feel
she's so light and focused upon her yeah
she's definitely um a different person
now yeah i love it i love that and i
never think i saw them
where the night they got married hours
before it's lyla so you were in vegas
yes were you at the grammys i was not at
the grammys i was that i got through the
night of the grammys not knowing those
grammys um i was there for rupaul's drag
race um finale they were filming there
wait oh [ __ ] i was front row i was on
the red carpet the finale has already
been filmed it's in films do you know
who wins no no one knows no one knows
they don't announce it until
um so what was the finale
the finale
most times it is live no it's not live
you said it was already filmed well it's
not am i getting in trouble for this no
no it's like wait it's um it's like
no they film it it's not it's never live
but then the winner is announced live no
the winner's announced so the winner
finds out when we find out
that they said that's live i know
um
is this live yeah
um okay whatever we can move past it but
how was that it was phenomenal that's
amazing i love all the queens this
season was so good we just
announced good all stars i know
all-stars all-stars who do you think is
going to win
of this season yeah i know who i want to
win i'm rooting for there's five the
five guys i went to the finale i just
know who i'm not rooting for and that's
diabetes
[ __ ] yes hate she's so nasty
like she i can't believe she's made it
this far she's so mean to everyone i'm
rooting for either lady camden or bosco
oh i love how lady camden has come out
of her shell like and i think that's
exactly what the journey on rupaul is
supposed to be about um but bosco's been
at the top even though like that one
episode where bosco almost got
eliminated and was really the kanji bar
was so mean to lady camden like that was
a big step down for me in terms of bosco
but i do believe bosco is probably the
most qualified to win who do you think i
think well you know i think that's quite
right i'm a big willow pill fan i've
been a big willow pill fan too um but
she's kind of been lacking and she
doesn't win a lot of challenges true
that so i'm i'm i'm team if i had to
pick two i'd be team willow pill and
team
bosco also honorable mention to angeria
oh stop i love her i know she like
started friends just call me angie she
came out really strong in the beginning
but kind of like fell by the wayside and
just like was safe
i think the snatch game really shook
everyone up rattle everyone's feathers
that was embarrassing yeah embarrassing
what would you do on snatch game oh my
god probably joan rivers oh good one but
that's kind of predictable yeah maybe
celine dion thank you
oh what about you
um
i don't know you should do sneaky yeah i
could do her would you ever go on track
did you do drag i used to know when i
was like when i was a young girl i did
you did yeah in clubs like yeah and i
used to work the door at the tunnel and
what was your shtick on stage um i
didn't really
back then it wasn't about like i didn't
do that kind of thing we just kind of
danced like [ __ ] right on like
i'm like did you like dance moves to
like whitney houston remixes and things
like that and like you know show up at
parties and things we have to go to a
drag show together soon oh yes i've been
going a lot to um
barracuda
yes
with
the points guys yes and i went to like a
few weeks in a row for their miss
barracuda dragon pageant stunning
facility yeah i was actually thinking of
having my birthday party there oh with
the queens i thought that would be so
funny how fun is that
um
so you got to do the red carpet and how
was that oh so good the the girls were
so sweet and it was that was like it was
like pinch me moment like i've seen you
know i i kind of follow vicariously in
your footsteps like i've looked up to
you for so many years
because you were so young when you
started it and you like you did
everything the right way in the right
order and you like you just kind of but
there's no right way there's no right
way there's no right way and you're like
in your season now yeah so i kind of
felt what you guys did with me i was
always so jealous of watching jackie go
to um the country music awards right all
those things and i said oh my god i
would love to do that so i manifested it
for myself so now trish and i yeah
you interviewed like the queens on the
carpet yeah we interviewed them as they
were they were going in for the big um
for the big moment um just the top five
or all the queens who showed up there
was a lot of queens there there was
queens um old and watched yeah
can't just were trixie and katya there
um i can't say okay will you tell me
after yeah i'll tell you after there was
there was there was there was a a host
of all different queens
amazing i love that that sounds so fun
yeah it was so much fun and the show was
incredible i actually left it a little
early
why you had to poop
well
no i forgot what happened was oh you had
too many drinks no they stopped from
serving drinks and inside outside to go
out and get something yeah of course i
never came back i went to the bar and
didn't come back have you seen the
rupaul's drag show in vegas at the
flamingo not yet have you yes i went to
vegas for a weekend and i started twice
it was so good i cried the first time
like it was because i'm a huge coco
montrese girl oh yeah and she's like
very niche and i didn't know she was
gonna be there that night and she was
and i was just like
speechless i thought it's an amazing
show the
music is incredible and they have
obviously like rupaul's songs but then
they also have you know greatest showmen
and like lady gaga they had everything
derek berry was there she does a great
britney oh i have to show you
a video because they do like a trivia
and they came to me for trivia and it
was like a season one question i'm like
i don't [ __ ] know and i made like a
little joke and derrick barry left and
it was like this gorgeous moment oh my
god how fun wait we can literally go we
have to actually hang out after this
because we have so much this show will
be 10 hours i know i know okay we got to
move on the girls in the games get it
together
before before do you have your coffee
yet i did i mean it's like kind of gross
a milkshake it's milk ma'am that's a
milkshake i'll speaking i bought you a
ma'am hat oh
it's my bag there okay i'll get it
afterwards thank you so much okay we do
need to move on you're 100 right
um the next story is brought to you by
luminesce
if you don't have a ton of time to get
ready in the morning we're always
looking for ways to put on makeup faster
and easier and it's impossible for me to
find the perfect makeup tone so that's
why you've got to check out luminess and
their new breeze cordless airbrush
makeup the breeze is completely
touchless way to put on foundation it's
so fast and easy to use there's no
sponges brushes or fingers that you need
to keep clean with luminesce you get
three times more coverage while using 10
times less makeup it's designed to work
with all skin types and skin tones their
water-based foundation quickly and
easily covers fine lines and wrinkles it
conceals imperfections and applies
flawlessly in seconds the breeze
airbrush is handheld cordless and
rechargeable so you can bring it
wherever you need plus it features a no
mess tip that prevents it from spraying
in your hair and eyes luminesce is
available in 18 shades so they've got a
color for every skin type and will
replace the shade for free if it doesn't
match so i love using it it's so tiny
it's perfect for travel on tour my
makeup on stage stays so nice and matte
and fresh and it's just really premium
so whether you're heading back to the
office updating your beauty routine or
just looking for a better faster way to
put on foundation we've got good news
right now if you go to breezetoday.com
toast and put in promo code toast you'll
receive 50 off their airbrush makeup
system plus free shipping and because
you're a listener there's a special free
gift included just for you that's 50 off
plus free shipping when you go to
breezetoday.com
toast don't forget you get 30 days to
try out the luminess breeze and if you
don't love it send it back for a full
refund all right ready joey we are
making no progress we're only on the
third story so let me get my [ __ ]
together
side note i've tried luminess and it's
actually very nice i know it's very
lightweight and fresh it's stunning i
feel like you're probably
going to feel cooling and fresh and i'm
sweaty buddies i love a cool blast of
air on my face
um so elon musk you know we reported
last week that he bought like nine
percent stake in twitter because he's
like mad at the company he wants to make
changes but now he's made an official
bid he wants to own twitter he offered
over 40 billion dollars to take the
company private how is he so rich he's
the richest man in the world they said
so he um started
paypal
he did yeah
then paypal sold to ebay for a big ass
chunk of money
then he obviously started tesla and
spacex that are just it has spacex
making that's all space ships yeah i
think they make they make money i don't
know but tesla is like there's no one
bread and butter i think now but i don't
know if it's more i think i think it's
more money than what does that sound
obscure the world the rich man in the
world i heard on tension wins all the
way over here 10 10 wins is up the new
york thing fire newton radio station
yeah
yeah world don't you think wouldn't you
think some like saudi prince or
something totally i thought it's an
american is he american i thought he was
the richest in america no it's that well
ten times into the world they give you
give them ten minutes they give you the
world
okay that is their slogan and it's been
that's their slogan since i was
literally i know you guys 22 minutes
we'll give you the world yes
um but he wants to buy twitter now 40
billion dollars um
he um
famously hates twitter right so he
offered to pay fifty four dollars per
share for a hundred percent of ownership
of twitter he said that he wants to take
the company private the offer would
value the social site at about 43
billion dollars for per bloomberg so the
billionaire added that he would
be reconsidering his role as a
shareholder with the company if his
offer was not accepted so he's kind of
threatening them um i love this i think
twitter is the most toxic place on the
internet and any sort of change can't be
bad yeah do you think there's still a
lot of nude photos though because that's
my favorite part of it you know what i
like no censorship i have to agree
because anytime like i'm on tick tock
and someone's like did you see like
so-and-so sex tape like i run into
twitter yeah yeah so i hope that element
doesn't change even though um it's like
kind of [ __ ] up yeah i don't know i
don't think that's elon's i'm pretty
sure elon's overall message is like free
speech censorship i think he thinks
twitter is censoring people so i think
he's not really worried about our nude
photos he's like
like censoring like not being able to
like like political i don't like like
our the old president yeah right that's
censorship when you can't win it yes
they want them on there i'm pretty sure
like he doesn't like that twitter
decides what is considered appropriate
and what is considered not
i'm pretty sure that's what it is i'm
not 100 sure please don't quote me on
that um so it's more of like a statement
on censorship and free speech and i
think he'll leave our nude photos alone
thank god
yeah i just want to be freely just like
my nip slips i know do you have any nude
leaked photos yes
you don't know about this on twitter
it's not a leaked photo it's a it's a
video of me climaxing on my own face
and
years ago this is i sent this video this
before i even had tattoos there's an old
video and i just must have sent it to a
guy before i was famous um so you're
alone i'm alone i'm pleasuring myself oh
and that guy sent it around people are
so evil well that's it good luck to you
sister either they're pretending to be
me you're trying to get money for it's
like
best of luck to you girl yeah right
you're not gonna get my farm with that
[ __ ] picture i don't think it's go
they're going great so it's a video or
like a still thought photo
it's a gif and a video and where does
one find it i can show you it yeah do
you want to see it yeah right now it's a
gif it's gross though it's okay no it's
really graphic no i have seen worse less
of jizz going everywhere that's okay
i've seen worse okay
now this is not forget i'm like pretty
much a gay man and it was a video that
goes around the office now uh everyone
where do you have it saved like in your
photo album she's under animated if you
find my phone ever it's under go to
animated
and then go to um
oh what you've lost so much weight since
then thank you that's kind of like hot
it's not really that gross thank you i'm
proud of you so that's my new photo leak
now do you have any nudes no well how
much money would it take for you to leak
a nude of one of your sisters oh one of
my sisters like what would you trade
like if like 30 what is your ultimate
goal you just want to be a billionaire
yeah 30 billion dollars but for me i
would agree to sis like taking a nude
photo
and putting it out there for a small
amount of money if i was able to face
two in the photo that's really yeah
that's all i personally care about true
that and as long as i'm like i have a
tan and my hair is blown out if i was
hot with a big dick like i'd be naked
all the time no i know and it's like
for me i think the
the idea of having nudes leaked wouldn't
feel to me like
an invasion of my privacy which i think
a lot of people feel i would feel like
oh my god i need to go on a diet like so
that's what that's my concern and i
think other people's concern is like you
know it's an invasion and it is but for
me i'm more worried about you know the
badass yeah i love facetune
i love your face app that's even better
of course oh my god don't tell pay all
the money don't tell people about that
oh my god that's a secret isn't it like
they don't pay 30 a month for that i
literally i would pay 100
i'll trade in my equinox membership for
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] literally um
okay next story is justin timberlake is
like fighting with paparazzi because a
paparazzi asks him like what do you
think about brittany and he's like
literally screaming go away go away stop
and the question that the paparazzi had
asked was like hey what's up justin how
are you doing britney spears just
announced that she's pregnant with her
third baby and he's like stop go away go
away [ __ ] baby i literally hate this
man did you see
um her jason alexander of her husband's
messed out screaming
no oh
the fact that britney was married to
someone named jason alexander and it's
not
seinfeld guy uh what's his [ __ ] name
jason alexander oh oh
yeah the guy what's his name george
stanza stanza thank you his name is also
jason alexander and i find it really
confusing
it was on
where did she send this to me so he sent
it to me yesterday
so he is talking about brittany
yes all of brittany's ex is coming out
of the woodwork screaming can i should
we show can i show you this this is
premium person of course it was on
perez hilton i believe broke the news
yeah here it is
there he is okay press that this is
jason alexander he looks nothing like
himself he looks messed out he's
spitting and slurring
in the street oh wow he looks so
different he's definitely on meth he's
from florida
isn't he i don't know he looks so
different
all of britney's exes are like really um
losing it yeah so she's pregnant justin
timberlake is out here yelling at
paparazzi when you know what he has some
nerve to be yelling at anyone after what
they literally dated at some they were
seven years old why is it because
celebrities is like i know why do you
live here and selena never be separated
so stupid but do you think you think
that justin timberlake is the one that
like thinks britney's the one that got
away no
who do you think is the one that got
away from britney
oh
is it federline i don't know like they
we're a family yeah
i don't know i think
maybe we haven't met him yet maybe i
don't think we had him yet maybe it is
uh what's this guy's name sam ashkari he
was just in a movie i saw no way
our show was watching what kind of movie
he plays someone in the show i was
watching i love that for him good you
know gotta get work those bills aren't
gonna happen i've been watching the girl
from plainville no but it's like on my
list and you know what uh what's the
girl the name of the girl play who plays
she looks so much like that [ __ ] it's
crazy such a good job the forehead
the eyebrows the forehead the
hair she's the sneaky lesbian who is
the
the character the character the real
lady the real lady i thought that she
was but she had a boyfriend yeah but
it's his whole switzerland you have to
watch the show oh yeah i know i've heard
it's incredible it's on my way out if we
don't get money from hulu from sponsor
we talked about kardashians and this
other show and i heard people are loving
the dropout speaking of hulu the
elizabeth holmes
but i am so i don't want to watch
anything that's slanderous of elizabeth
holmes because in my mind she's an
american hero and a girl boss yeah
that's the lady that's a blessed bee
lady that's like the theranose blood
girl but it's just the same lady that
wears your little red outfit and says
blessed be
no that's elizabeth moss from
scientology and from
handmaid's tale yep so a lot of people
say it's like hypocritical of her to be
in that show because she's in a cult
yeah i'm excited for brittany to have a
new baby her other babies are kind of
[ __ ] how do you how do you mean like
didn't weren't they like turning on her
like and they were like going with the
father and like and then the grandfather
like well we all know about jamie
what's him he was like hitting them or
something yes that's what it was said in
some court documents yeah i don't know
much about her kids and she keeps them
very private and i want them to have as
normal of a life as possible because
yeah i don't know what their whole
family and i think kevin vettel's like a
really good dad i think he has primary
custody
you know who knew the backup dancer
turned father of the year no i know it's
a beautiful love story and you just love
to see happy endings yeah so justin
justin needs to calm down and stop
touching the paparazzi 100
and then speaking of weird interactions
there is this video going viral of um
machine gun kelly and megan fox they're
on a red carpet somebody just like got
this video where they look like they
[ __ ] hate each other and like he
leans in for a kiss and like she swerves
and i just want to say i don't think
it's fair to like take a moment out of
context because i love my husband more
than anything but if you followed us
around all the time with cameras you
would and you posted it you would be
like trouble in paradise like yeah sorry
people are human you don't always want
to be kissed you're wearing a lot of
makeup like i hate when people try to
make like a moment out of everything
because people are people
and
not everyone is going to be happy all
the time i think the problem with that
is that why it got to that point is
because they are so overly affectionate
just like the courtney and travis
they're always tonguing each other down
so the second that they're not everyone
thinks oh her trouble in paris but also
they could have had a blowout fight in
the [ __ ] car like i told you i wanted
sushi [ __ ] right now here we are
at the burger joint it's like
i said you picked last week it could be
something as simple as that and just get
the [ __ ] away from me you're up my ass
all the time no it's not annoying no
they're so annoying and you know even
the best relationships like you want to
kill your partner and just normalize
being miserable in relationships that
are still very healthy and good right
i'm sorry i have to go that's one thing
i won't like when i was liberty yeah
well you're well on your way thank you
are you thinking of dating another
celebrity i think that would be really
good for you hate that but i think it
would be really good for your career
anyone i would do you think billy on the
street and i are too much
too toxic i do think he's got a hot
little body on him i love him i do think
your energy and billy eichner's energy
like clashing might start like a world
war it's so chaotic
but i don't hate it you know what colton
underwood and i were um canoodling for a
while
not not sexually friendly friendly this
is this before he first came out of
course i latched on to him like a true
thurston
true thirst monster i have to say when
he came out every gay man in my phone
was like do you
know him can i have his number every
single person and now he's engaged yeah
well i slipped i slept yeah that's
that's he was gay for five [ __ ] weeks
and he's had a [ __ ] engaged husband
in a [ __ ] house and you've been gay
for how long you're trying to sell his
wedding to the not common people people
for the exclusive and i've been gay for
72 years
now that's it that's a hundred years in
dog years
and
i i can't catch a dick if i try okay now
this queen is like i can't with her so
we've been she actually goes to me and i
was like
yes because i was in town a couple weeks
ago and we were we dm each other he was
like oh my god
i'm in town
um i think i know i saw he was in town
and then i talked to him i said oh my
god you're in town let's hang out he
goes okay let's do it we've had plans to
go to two different plans and he goes to
me both times he well they changed him
last time he changed last minute both
times so i said to him i said oh my god
my dreams are coming true like dream big
girls i'm actually getting ghosted by
colton underwear right now who would
have thought it's true it's better to be
ghosted than nothing at all yeah so um
but we never we never talked
romantically but in my head you know who
knows
what fantasies yeah okay but he would
have quite a catch if you could date any
celebrity you have to be gay though yeah
yeah i'm sorry that does limit the fun
but
who would you want to be married to
oh right now
um that bowmer is pretty hot oh my god i
can't go hot guy like that and the guy
from bridgeton is gay the lead andrew um
the one who plays the vi count this time
i'd probably go with like carl nasib
who's like the gay raider the football
player that came out oh he's cute yeah i
i could be a whop what do i call a
waffle
a wag wife and girlfriend yeah you would
be an amazing wag
that's what i think i'm doing at work
anyway you could you could do the glam
for all the other wags like that would
be so fun they would love to have you
that's why i feel at barstool because
everyone's with sports there they're all
sporty spice i already feel like a wagon
i feel like i won already but yeah i
would go with him because he's he's like
uh butch queen right she's much queen
um she has a big salary yeah our my my
my like um
whoring myself out for fame is quite
different than hers yeah like he's gonna
play his football play little sports i'm
you know going to do things like this
he's going to be taking photos on the
field for instagram like this what do
you think of jackson mahomes
annoying or no um i have a special place
i was just in kansas city last weekend
and i was literally searching for him
because i really wanted to talk to him
just to give him some advice i think
that the kids on tick tock are so
[ __ ] that was he gay
um
i don't know not on the record no
sweetie so just let yourself be i want
to talk to him because i want to give
him some advice but i also think the
kids on tick tock are so [ __ ] mean to
him like they call him mahomo like it's
so mean she never slammed you sure
use gay slurs never was that a slur not
you oh okay i'm saying people like
shouldn't be like making you feel better
about being gay people are [ __ ] about
it thirst monster making annoying yeah
he's talking in the wrong time he's so
annoying like on tick tock but i think
that like
i got vertigo juggle those dancers
are you on tick-tock well it's on
tick-tock yeah i don't ever use it
though i i just think it's like you know
all those how many boys in those
gray sweatpants i know there's so many
dpls i know you need to get a pair of
dick dick lines like
vpl vpls
you need to get a pair of gray
sweatpants and start swinging it in
front of the camera and then you'll go
viral well that's what it takes
that's what it takes all those tick
tuckers always hang out by dave portnoy
yeah do you see them around the office
yes those little twinks what
what what do you think about them which
ones i don't know their names the josh
richards i think works there and then
bryce hall oh unique
i mean they're beautiful young boys
stunning very very handsome kids
i just you know i get sick i get it i
get it i guess that was you watching
that was the meat
because they're that skinny
um but yeah there's chick chocolate
tonight you know brianna chicken fries
she's a big tic tacker she's always over
there in a bikini you know tic-tac-toe
checking around i just i just can't do
the silly videos and it's not to say and
that's what this is my shady take this
yeah you take on tick tock this is safe
space is everyone nags me oh my god go
on do this do this do this it's like
i don't have to go um on tick-tock and
um lip-sync to someone else's [ __ ]
jokes like like you and i are the joke
makers
we make the sounds yeah we are so that's
why i feel stupid going like saying even
if it's like some other
like lip syncing but you got to play the
game joey yeah i know i have to do it so
those were the fast five i feel like we
didn't really cover anything but i loved
every moment of it um and now we're
gonna do our advice segment called dear
toasters and i'm very excited to hear
your heart
watch and is those printed cards or did
you write with your hands no these are
printed they dry erase they're from
vistaprint use code toast okay no
they're not dry erase they're literally
not on your side
the ones that you write on did you write
into handwriting or no uh oh you want
all these secrets we print our ours very
professional thank you did you do that
yep i don't do it i can't lie um okay
the deer toaster segment is brought to
you by function of beauty the key to
consistent good hair days is using
ingredients that found how many
commercials you have one episode this is
the last one using ingredients that
benefit your hair function of beauty
makes hair care products that are 100
customizable made for your hair where
it's at now and where you want it to go
your hair is completely unique and
products that address its specific needs
and that's where function of beauty
comes in they're the world's first fully
customizable hair care that creates
individually filled shampoos
conditioners styling and treatment
formulas based on your hair now and
where you want to go founded by a dream
team of engineers and cosmetic
scientists each function of beauty
product is individually designed to be
as unique as you are they offer over 40
54 trillion possible formulations every
one of them is vegan cruelty free and
they never use sulfates or power bins
you can also go completely silicone free
here's how it works you'll take their
hair quiz to build your hair profile and
select your hair goals so i definitely
my goals are always to keep my hair
growing stop breakage shine
or whatever your problems if you have
oily hair if you have dry hair they'll
help you find the formula that's perfect
for you so if your hair gets frizzy in
the winter but oily in the summer their
formulations can change to keep up with
the seasons so
you can also choose your color and
fragrance i don't like fragrance in my
shampoo um then get your freshly filled
formula delivered straight to your dorm
say goodbye to generic hair care for
good go to functionalbeauty.com toast to
take your hair goals quiz and you'll
save 25 off in your first order go to
functionalbeauty.com toast to let them
know you heard about it from our show
and to get 25 off your first order
function of beauty.com toast take the
hair quiz and save 25 you write your
name on the shampoo i know it's nice it
makes me feel special are you ready to
change lives with some advice i am i'm
here i'm here to teach the children okay
hello joey and claudia my boyfriend and
i have been together for 10 years since
high school he was away in the military
for four years and we've been currently
living together for another four years
we always talk about marriage and how
many kids we're going to have so i
assumed we were eventually going to get
married we recently went on a big trip
together where i assumed he was going to
propose and when he didn't i was like
what the [ __ ] so i approached him asking
what his plans were and he told me he
doesn't think he ever wants to get
married or have kids anymore this is the
first i've heard of it and i'm so
confused and honestly heartbroken he
said he doesn't want to break up just
continue our lives how it is now
now i'm not sure what to do with my life
stay with him like
with the possibility of no marriage or
kids or do i leave him in the hopes of
finding that help a very confused
toaster she needs to watch that movie
what's that movie crossing delancy no
it's the one where it's like it was
jennifer anderson she's like and then
and then he's just not that into you
is that what it is when ben affleck
doesn't want to get married yeah and
then she then shows up with the cargo
pants and proposes on the boat yeah yeah
yeah that's what
she doesn't have to go like no the thing
is there's nothing worse on the planet
than a man who wastes a woman's time
because as women we are
you know being held in a chokehold by
this biological clock and so now it's
ten years and this [ __ ] never
thought once to bring it up um and thank
you for your service sir but you are a
dick like such a dick so
first of all you need to decide do you
want kids like it sounds like you are
toying with the possibility of staying
with him if you want kids do not stay
with me how do you not know that your
partner doesn't get married after 10
years i know which i know what he ate
for [ __ ] breakfast two months ago so
on the day so he's a dick for not
telling you but also like this is a
lesson for you to learn like you need to
know what people like you have to put
all your cards on the table at a certain
point it's not fun you're not dating
like cool you're old now you got to
figure out what is my life's plan it's
very like militaristic and honestly if
you want kids and you want to get
married you got to say goodbye and it's
going to be hard but get it over with
because yeah your time's running out
like
if you want kids it's harder and harder
the older you get so you have to keep
that in mind a great advice yeah i mean
i would just put it on the table this is
something that's important to me
something i want we don't got much time
here what are we doing girl it's it's
it's just yesterday we asked a question
do you want kids
at this age i mean andy cohen did it so
i know that but i think if i become rich
enough i'll have a kid i don't care it's
not i want to have kids like i want to
be able to have afford to do it the
right way nanny
yeah a nanny you know multiple nannies
multiple houses yeah of course things
like that travel school i'm really sorry
that this happened to you yeah i'm sorry
girl this sucks to feel like you wasted
your time so if you
if you sit and think to yourself like i
really do want kids you gotta bounce
from this relationship thousands of men
that want kids and are ready to [ __ ]
do it right away and who are wasting 10
years 10 prime years of a young girl's
life but also fine this guy might just
make me afraid of marriage
he may have had parents that like
divorced divorced and he was terrified
but he doesn't want to leave her he
wants the kids he just thinks marriage
freaks him out
the best thing to do is just you got to
speak it out and leave nothing out
enough yeah it sounds like there's a lot
unsaid between you two you might not
have great communication yeah you got to
be like very blunt and
do you want to do this yeah like
be be meticulous go get it girl go get
it you got it you got it all right next
up i need both of your advices so badly
so to frame this story i was invited
last july to this billionaire summer
house i was invited by a friend of a
friend this is from claudia ashrae
i was invited by a friend of a friend so
i didn't really know anyone there the
same weekend one of the billionaire's
sons was also there with his friends
from college i ended up flirting with
the billionaire's son and we drunk we
drunkenly hooked up that
we didn't talk since except for one time
where he messaged me a few months later
asking me to come out to a club on a
sunday but i told him i was staying in
club on a sunday
fast forward to this past weekend where
i ran into his dad the billionaire while
i was out on a wednesday we ended up
talking he asked for my number to get
dinner the next night and i agree i get
dinner with him the next night and he's
genuinely the most sweetest interesting
person i've ever met then he asks me to
grab a drink with him on sunday the
night before he has a dinner with his
sons i agree with the intention of
dipping out before his son's she's with
the
man dad she's with the dad getting a
drink with him before the sons arrive
like he's having dinner with his sons
but he grabs a drink with this girl
before
so she says
um
but she already hooked up with one of
the sons yep she says i stupidly agree
with the intention of dipping out before
the sun arrives so i meet him at the bar
and then 30 minutes later his ex-wife
arrives it's a little bit awkward but i
sense they have a healthy co-parenting
relationship and she was very nice to me
she mentioned that the suns are on their
way so i call an uber so i can avoid an
awkward run-in before i get there of
course my uber is taking forever but
when it finally arrives the billionaire
says he'll walk me outside we get
outside and i see both of his sons a
block away walking towards us one of
what she hooked up with yep he goes why
don't i introduce you to my sons i panic
and make up an excuse that my uber's
been waiting a while and i'll meet them
another time he even says it's more
awkward if i don't say hi since his sons
are literally walking towards us at this
point i say sorry and just sprint to my
uber i'm not sure if they saw me
but i know at some point if i keep on
seeing him i'll have to talk to him
about the sun do you think i should tell
the billionaire or should i reach out to
his son to see if we can agree not to
tell his dad where's the loyalty though
is she is she's really trying to hook up
with the with the man i think her heart
is with the dad now
my heart would be with the dad too like
you want something she had a whoops of
daisy she went to the party hoping to
hook up with the father i don't think
she was thinking about it but she just
ended up hooking up with the sun and
then months later i know she's wishing
she didn't because she actually is
hitting it off with the billy and her
dad
i got it okay so so she went to the
party was an open agent yeah she just
came like as a friend of a friend
happened to hook up with a son
never heard from him again
oh and then she said she's still she's
kept out of contillion's house
amend him again okay i got it girl
first of all i'll take the sun
true no problem with that
what a pickle i know because it's like
like an ashton kutcher movie that were
there in that movie it's an ashton
kutcher movie for sure yeah i like i
really want this to work out between you
and the dad because like you being a
billionaire like you have billionaires
listen to your show that's just good for
the toast yeah so i really want to help
you and i don't know is the best way for
her to like speak to the sun and be like
we can never tell your dad
or to be honest with the dad i don't
know it's different you know the worst
so i've support girls she probably like
there's going her head imagine the son's
secretly in love with the girl and then
his heart's going to be broken and he'll
never accept her when she gets married
to the family that's not going to happen
because they hooked up once and never
spoke again and like he doesn't like her
like that yeah but it's just gross like
i don't
i i think that family members shouldn't
hook up with the same person i think
it's gross i want to know the age things
this girl had to be and the girl has to
be somewhere in between the age of the
father and the son right and like and
the holy spirit
[Laughter]
i don't know what to tell you i for me
honesty is really always the best policy
always so i think you should tell the
dad but maybe maybe wait till he buys
you a bergen
yeah like get a couple gifts
um don't sleep with him but like make
sure you get a car or something because
before you sleep with him well there's
well she can't sleep with him without
telling him that she [ __ ] the sun
oh so she needs to get all she can that
she has already
no i don't think she has
she needs to get all she can out of the
relationship and then tell him just in
case he never wants to see her again
yeah at least she has a birkin for the
memories you know a porsche for the road
how would you say the craziest
montgomery the craziest thing happened
the other day at the party discovery
about literally
like one thing led to another we were
sipping champagne next thing i'm
gobbling down your son's penis
i think that's how brothers talk
yeah i think that's how they talk too i
don't know i'm sure they do i don't know
if they're from the south but they
definitely talk like that montgomery
where did you come up with the name
montgomery
what is the fanciest name you can think
of uh that's a good question what's the
most like regal fancy name well whenever
i'm pretending to be rich i always
pretend like i'm talking to my butler
chives would you fetch me maybe
montgomery is the butler i don't know
montgomery is a rich name yeah but i
always my go-to is chives would you
fetch me what's this baby's name
a harry harry yeah i think he point to
the couch like that's that's that
doesn't get too much
how's young mark marjorie marjorie's
doing amazing thank you for asking she's
thriving still doing the live method
always you know working out before six
a.m dog hurts the weather and i follow
her i only i get my weather from her
i the other day i knew it was raining
and then she told me i was gonna get
sunny out the next day she said so make
sure you know you bring it's gonna get
hot out yes she's quite reliable when it
comes to the weather all right here's
our third and final quandary i don't
feel like we've really given anyone any
good advice so let's try this time okay
yeah
my fiance and i recently hired a
cleaning service to come to our house
every other week rich we have a puppy
and a new house and things can get
pretty messy so we figured we could use
some help a couple of weeks ago i came
home from work to find that the bag of
peanut butter cups i store in our fridge
had only one remaining i had just bought
them
i had just bought them the day before
and i figured it was odd that my fiance
had eaten almost all of them when i
asked him about it he said he didn't
need any of them it's just the two of us
that lived together so i started racking
my brain thinking who could have eaten
them the only people in our house that
day were my fiance because he works from
home and the cleaning crew of two
since they take out the trash each time
they leave we decided to check the trash
outside oh my you're [ __ ] nuts just
buy more peanut butter cups since they
take out the trash each time they leave
we decided to check the trash outside to
be sure just before coming jumping to
conclusions lo and behold there were
peanut butter cup wrappers in the trash
that they had taken out how do i
approach this do i confront them or let
it slide it's not about the peanut
butter cups being gone i could care less
it's about them rooting through the
fridge when we're not paying attention
and could this escalate and become worse
would love to know your thoughts girl
you have like literally no problems in
your life if this is the biggest problem
that's right you need a reality check
this woman came to clean your house and
she got hungry like i would have been
the whole bag i wouldn't have even left
one i have they can have anything they
want yeah out of my house like if you're
like doing the [ __ ] i have to do like
the lady folds the laundry and puts in
my drawers it's like
take whatever take whatever you want
yeah no totally and you know what maybe
like this is a lesson were you offering
them refreshments or beverages they're
back breaking work did you put the air
conditioning on maybe they're [ __ ]
hot and they were hot and hot trying to
cool off though with a nice piece of
their head in the fridge and then they
saw oh you know i haven't eaten in hours
because this [ __ ] didn't put on any
cheese sandwiches sugar was low so she
had did what she had to do i think
you're toxic and you're the problem
no seriously this is not a big deal like
you need to
you need to move on you sound just like
a major control freak and maybe you
should just start cleaning your own
house because you can't handle the
pressure i'm glad you said it yeah i i
don't see anything wrong with this was
the most dramatic thing i've ever read
like i know
girl relax
not the peanut butter cups you act like
she stole your gold bracelet like she
didn't oh
did you watch um cindy sweetie in that
show which one white lotus bracelet oh
yeah so good so good what do you think
of sydney sweeney i think she's gorgeous
a star a star i think and her facial she
can say so much without saying a damn
word yeah she's very talented what is
that now oh this is my little instrument
oh
let's do this
[Music]
is that the is that does that mean the
show's over it's about to be over i just
wanted to show you before i i love it
thank you do you want to play with that
i'd be honored here
place it too morning toast on it no
place a tune
this remember um greece that's what i
said the first time i opened it
gorgeous
thank you so much
joey on percussion
joey i love you more than life you are
one of the funniest people i want to
come here all the time you are always
welcome i love you thank you for coming
thank you for having me check out joey's
podcast out and about podcast it's a
barstool podcast it is so funny please
do and like sure follow us on instagram
and about out about out out and about
and then put pod yeah that's the
instagram and my instagram is mr peace
every night miss you gotta change that
but i thought you get in trouble when
you change it jackie ashrae did it yeah
and she didn't get in trouble by who
everyone said that if you change your
names to your real name that they can
[ __ ] up the algorithms and stuff no i
think that if you're verified you just
have to like do it with instagram you
can't just do it in your phone like you
have to just ask someone to help you
change it oh really is that what she did
i think so oh
because i i love you but what the [ __ ]
is mr p it's my nickname when i was a
kid okay but you're a grown ass man now
but i can change it to my phone without
getting like losing everything i'm
pretty sure all right so it's right now
it's mr him hammer s-m-i-s-t-e-r-p-79
and you can catch him on the out about
podcast on the it's happening snooki and
joey podcast and they're heading out on
tour so if you want to check out tickets
for their unhinged live show it's
nicolepolisse.com correct i remember
everything and then look for high noon
in your cities if you're in nashville no
don't don't oh no look for sports
society we're in uh we're in stores
we're at total wine we're at bevmo and
also spritsociety.com use code toast
there we go i love you thank you so much
thank you for having me you guys chose
to be nice to me please don't rip me
apart on the internet thank you so much
for listening to the morning testimonial
morning show where we deliver the five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcasts anywhere podcasts can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio ir radio cat box all the
places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find out some morning shows and
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are have
an amazing day everyone tomorrow we'll
see you for friday tomorrow
bye
you